Chris and I had the opportunity to
finally get down to the National farm
machinery show it was our first time
ever actually going I wanted to go for
years but running my business and being
such a small business it's hard for me
to get away for that many days and not
be able to do all the other stuff I have
to do but this year I bit the bullet and
went down there and it was a lot of fun
we got to see all sorts of stuff
it's been a couple days there or parts
of a couple of days talking to a lot of
folks the second day we saw things that
we missed the first day either you walk
right by it or there's so many aisles
that well you just get confused on what
you saw and what you didn't and they
have stuff for tractors big and small I
mean a lot of the the equipment that was
there is not really relevant to to my
business and to what I I sell or what I
use either but it's still cool to see
some of that really big equipment in
person that's in pristine conditions
right brand new showroom quality but of
course there were plenty of different
tools and tractors and all sorts of
Brands you can sit out and try them out
and see how they felt so a really good
opportunity if you ever get the chance
to go I'd highly encourage you to do so
they say if there's one show you're
going to go to this is the one we bumped
into a whole pile of YouTubers out there
too so you'll probably see some familiar
faces in the video but I thought we'd
just kind of take you through Mosey on
through all the boots that we saw just
kind of like you're there yourself so
let us know what you think here we go
foreign
okay so we're
let's get out of the way here
this is like this is like their 1025r
model right here
yeah
20s
see it's got one of those flip around
seats down there
oh there's no third function
yeah they're good looking tractors
they're good looking tractors
a lot of hydraulics there
it's cool Baylor
coyote
so where do we go oh I gotta check that
out so it's tree Terminator that could
be cool
no I'm just kind of looking around thank
you
well these guys uh the three foot one
oh it is a three-point mount
it's like a little mini one
I wonder if this fits on uh
if a subcompact would lift it
[Music]
things
a 20 inch
nasty okay
the hydraulic flow is almost the same on
the JCB all I need is 10 gallons a
minute oh okay at 2000 PSI wow so any 50
horsepower skid loaders got that oh yeah
for sure not much at all even for the
bigger one the 20 inch well 20 inch I
need 15 Gallons a minute but still any
skid loader today yeah
wow you just have to have the 20 inch
I'm looking at lift capacity okay
um weight lift capacity this weighs 1400
pounds the 20 inch weighs 2200 pounds
okay so yeah
capacity yeah but this one here is this
a 14 inch it's a 14. wow that's sweet it
only weighs 800 pounds but there's a lot
of head yeah every giant out there so is
this telescope or no telescope this
rotates okay swivel oh nice that's cool
that's handy so that's good for Limbs
and stuff then too on a skid loader you
got eight foot of reach here so you
ought to be able to reach up about 16
foot inside
that's sharp um what's the tree
Terminator that is that the mower well
tree Terminators are named oh it is oh
okay so all of these are tree Terminator
Okay um it's just they're made by Grace
manufacturing that just happens to be
our rotary mower okay what size does
that cut five inches in diameter okay
all right and what kind of clothes do
they use standard for 25 gallons 15 up
to 25. okay I'm gonna make a heavier
version of it that'll go up to 45
gallons and what diameter of that cut
eight inch
wow that's nice Oh okay that's cool how
do you guys sell
uh mostly through Distributors okay
depending on where you're located if we
have a distributor in your area or not
if we don't we just sell direct okay
where are you located at I am a dealer
in in Michigan so up in Michigan yeah
but I sell Farm Co is our distributor oh
are they oh okay yeah yeah I sell online
though I sell Nationwide so but you can
buy from Farm Co or good okay well
that's good to know our distributor up
there Grace man would it be under grace
manufacturing then yeah okay okay I'll
have to check that out that might be
worth looking into this is the Mulcher I
have right here
got that same one
KR 30.
I don't even have a rep here that looks
that looks sweet
that was Triple Sec or no double stack
aways
dang got a little bit of a counterweight
up here
[Music]
I didn't know anybody
very much
oh wait yeah they do
little thing
okay that way all the stuff's way back
there but you're still in total control
up here but it's all electric man wow
interesting is it the same series then
yeah it's the same sprayer it's just got
a
hearing much okay so in other words if
you want to do all three
eat and you need it to increase your
pressure a little bit to six eight ten
twelve twenty four maybe Twenty Eight
Five
26 I don't even know what to say
it seems like so much maintenance
appreciate
earthquake
um
thank you
this would be like I think this would be
like what the summit size is like
tab I think so yeah
[Music]
this must be like a
fairly economy model
73-20 power shuttle looks kind of like
the M4 huh
yeah it's pretty
pretty similar overall this must be the
is it not taller cab isn't it where's
the is this not the uh huh season other
than just looking no I'm just looking
around I'm looking for new manufacturers
to work with to fill out my lineup if I
need to
depends depends whatever you know I just
I want quality you know and good pricing
features accessibility you know so
I know your business model kind of
observed your business model yeah you
would like the gentleman over there on
the phone yeah these are yeah he kind of
Geeks out about that
are you doing anything with Summit are
you just just influencing some
attractors are you developing new
products or just trying to perfect the
one you have well I agree
so are you uh
now your equipment like
I'm taller than it
I just feel like all the moving Parts on
those things oh okay there's a PTO
proud
yeah I mean like this takes some random
pictures yeah are you um are you guys
still doing just the one pen and then
the bolt-on second pin yes I think it's
a big cost consideration
it's a
little if you needed this you know I'm
so I'm when I'm selling these to like a
five Series right look at yeah 520m or
something like that right that's cool
so you can retrofit though you're old
yes oh sweet you have that it's across
here you can do that that that's that's
huge it's one of the newest things
that's a big deal the location was great
I thought it is a good location yeah
it's really easy to get in there you
definitely weren't going to get anybody
that came back but yeah it works out do
you guys have any of the um like your
three-point stuff uh like you're I
didn't read that close I just saw like
they all posted it on there what's that
but he's there
over seven foot tall isn't it
I should just kept the manatee you know
[Music]
kind of miss it though
backhoe
doesn't yeah it's actually I feel like
this tubing here is a lot smaller North
Carolina
[Music]
that's where their headquarter does
doesn't say That's Where It's Made
[Music]
good y'all just looking around today is
that a foil more there too or is that a
trailer that's a chiller yeah okay so
flail flail more flail you're like the
only ones on the market that
yeah make a quick hitch compatible coil
mower oh sweet remember this is 1980. no
kidding wow
so yeah we manufactured North Carolina
but we've got dealers
oh they have Cedars too
wow
[Music]
this would be great though for around
the ponds you know
[Music]
it'd be fun to have a
blower mounted on the skid steer you
know
that'd be sweet
but that thing would chuck it you know
well actually uh the designer was fired
he was let go
so a lot of
contact in here
wow
I mean these grill guards I've seen a
few of these now they have like nothing
you know I don't quite understand that
there are no uh armrests
there's the only thing on this whole
Fender here is the joystick got your
controls up here though which is nice
wow this is quite basic
Ally huh
yeah
those are fat tires aren't they
[Music]
doing
wow
please do not sit or stand on more
foreign
56 Grand
[Music]
40 Grand
oh but you get a
h
where's that uh
figure one
[Music]
yeah that's sharp because you see it it
digs the initial softens it up this
flings it out and then it Smooths the
bottom of the trench right there
I think I've seen these on online before
[Music]
thank you
like the Kubota
batteries probably
nose
like it looks fake I will say look how
short these wraps are they're great
[Music]
that do what exactly
this is this drain a lake is that what
it is
how's it going good how are you good
good got some cool stuff here man looks
like it's built like a brick house wow
my sprinkling skids to your stuff now
and then but where are you from from
Michigan oh sure did this show that's
big yeah I know yeah well that's about
as big as they come for yes that's why
if you're going to go to one this seems
to be the one to go to
[Laughter]
too they do a lot of skid steer stuff
but I do I just yeah we're you know
we're by 30 miles from Quick attached oh
okay well we're getting a lot of uh
I guess Traction in uh
the Moultrie show oh really oh yeah
[Music]
it kind of shows it all
right
[Music]
okay so make sure they would both work
in there and so we wanted to just put
one in gotcha
[Music]
um
and the way this is
ground level okay ah yeah yeah
how much pressure
he keeps doing it you know
thank you
over here one pin One Bowl
yeah yep yep perfect
let's say these are a lifesaver
all right so let's see we gotta go
wow there's a whole other whole other
world in here isn't it
let's see I heard about you I've talked
to Hank I talked to other people talk to
you I don't know how we ever talk but I
know that's just how it goes you know
today huh yeah we got a meet and greet
yeah
yeah you had a bunch of people stopped
by I'm doing well how are you nice to
meet you in person do you know Tony yeah
we just bumped into each other yeah yeah
so I was looking around the rest of the
area for you but you're blending in and
everybody's here
[Music]
likewise I still don't know how you do
it doing a video every day man and I
tell you what Facebook has been really
good for me some people I know I know I
don't we put them we just download them
the same video we put on YouTube you
know
not really
[Music]
everybody
for eign
ERS on it
right right now okay wow 100 000 and
this will keep one wow actually when you
hit it you kind of get that that uh that
harmonic noise oh yeah yeah it is I
heard it there yeah
that's crazy man
no
okay good to see you yeah you too you do
yeah nice to see you yeah how's the show
fun yeah yeah we were here yesterday too
and uh you can't see it all well you
think you see it all one day and you
don't you miss all sorts of stuff you
know so but then you get pulled in
different directions and all that kind
of thing too so yeah big crowd out this
morning we're just talking about I think
it's bigger today than it was yesterday
yeah
it is it is but the line even to get in
was long just you know through parking
and all that but that's a good thing
approach
oh yeah hey you got anything that uh for
like compact tractors that maybe I
should take a look at
selling our root rate grapples like our
baby baby
um the light the light duty wrecks yeah
uh so I just looked at those the other
day
well so the big the huge concern with
small tractors is lift capacity right
and so like the work saver
I really prefer that I I think that does
a better job yeah this thing
you put a six inch branch in there it'll
just rattle ahead this bottom to pick
something up oh yeah it falls you know
Deuter right kind of clean up this you
end up standing it on Android yeah
weren't they yeah yeah they are a little
so no 72 then for like a four series
no
people would love to have a two inch
receiver in those Forks they would they
would
I'll just orders a whole pile and I and
I haven't bring a few skins you know
what do they come in six packs or 12
packs a game remember but um
so on right off the top of my head I
don't
I don't charge card okay and then the
pulverizing basket at the end that's
going to break down the rest of your
clumps and kind of give you a smooth
finish okay all right I think quite a
bit lower than one of these guys for
sure's on
big old
well but still even though the business
end down here
yeah oh wow and 30 days later it was
all right
uh because it's a bigger you know a
bigger beefier one
um
[Music]
I'll come by and see everybody you know
it's like the most the highest
concentration of YouTubers
I gotta get pictures I'm taking pictures
I can't post them because I ain't got no
signal
[Laughter]
[Music]
come from
okay well I got it I got a YouTube
channel but I mean mainly the small
compact tractor type stuff though
[Music]
it's like rain
foreign
[Music]
huh
what am I missing here
so there's some sights and sounds for
you just kind of well let's just say it
was a lot busier the second day than it
was the first I don't know what the last
couple days are like but we went the
first two days and and they got really
packed out
but man it was a good time I think we'll
probably make it down there again I just
kind of moseyed around and Chris
followed along with the camera I think
next time we do it though we'll probably
both be miked up a lot of good
well you're just noticing things right
so a lot of new equipment that you're
seeing you're trying to figure out what
some of it is or maybe what
differentiates it and so there was a lot
of good back and forth banter we talked
to quite a few reps too that was pretty
fun now of course we do sell tractor to
address that's one of the main reasons
we were there to kind of seek some new
manufacturers out but if you're looking
for something we'd love to have the
chance to earn your business check out
goodworkstructors.com we ship all over
the country every day of the week our
prices include shipping rewards and
financing too if you enjoyed today's
video we'd love to have you tag along
hit that subscribe button right down
below I want to thank you for taking
time out of your day to stop by and
until next time stay safe we'll see you
soon
[Music]
[Applause]
laughs
[Music]
[Applause]